bang-bang all right guys I've got max
here all the way from across the pond
thank you very much for coming thank you
for having me absolutely all right New
York not only is it a beautiful morning
we got lots to talk about let's start
with your background and then we can get
into all the crypto web 3 stuff
absolutely so my side half remaining
half luxembourgish grew up in Luxembourg
so you think about it probably grew up
in the country that's most known for its
banking system and being sort of the
evil corporate of nation-states in the
other hand also have a Romanian
background which is probably all the
countries that suffered the most via
communist regime for over 40 years
so that's somewhat shaped my opinions
into into what matters and what doesn't
matter in technology incidentally the
remaining background the communist
regime started as something that almost
seems like an interesting ideal States
where everybody's equal everybody has
equal opportunities very quickly that
platform risk if jumped in people
started getting their passports taken
away there was a surveillance state the
state's effectively controlled your
actions in the past and in the future
and that's one of the main drivers for
which I think this is one of the most
interesting technologies so two early
realizations in my life first of all I
enjoyed more I got more pleasure out of
owning part of the company or piece of
an adventure and any other is
materialistic good a lot of friends were
buying watches cars because most
interesting thing for me was buying sort
of into crowdfunding rounds for a lot of
early-stage startups then that shifted
to realizing that actually if you can
work with the entrepreneur and have a
personal relationship with them as well
it's even 10 times better so that was
the very first realizations and sort of
set out what I wanted to do there's a
second one which is slightly advanced
with that was that unfortunately most of
the technologies that were building
today all end up in some sort of an
optical society which I heard the
stories and lives through his family
that lived through sort of the communist
regime which was not an ideal state at
all but and what I mean by that is that
you end up with a data economy where
corporations give you a product for free
and you become the product effectively
by date they sell on your data or they
monetize on top of you
and that's not a future that makes sense
for me it's at least if that's word
technology brings us to end technology
and the original dream of the internet
which was supposed to connect us to open
communications to enable us to have
interactions with people across the
world without surveillance and that
dream has failed and so that set out
pretty easy or evident pathway into
starting investing into it the whole web
story space so working a couple of entry
funds after an engineering degree from
the payroll in London was actually on a
set set out to join Jaguar for a while
but the prospect of working on the
right-front spring of a wheel for two
years and then shifting on to the left
front spring of that same Jaguar for
another two years didn't quite make as
much sense and so joined a venture fund
in Luxembourg called Negros Capital
Partners thereafter joint venture is
based in Hamburg spent a lot of time
with some great people there Hare
Krishna Muller Jonathan Becker looking
at the blockchain space at a time was
almost a Bitcoin is dead this underlying
doctrine technology is interesting I
think we all remembered that sort of
thread of thought luckily not too many
investments were made and investment
thesis of most people have shifted back
but that really started early on so the
interest but also the thinking around
where value will accrue in the long term
in his face and then joined up notion
which was a venture capital fund based
out of Helsinki and wouldn't London
office they basically are the team that
build MySQL or my sequel one of the
largest database in the world but also
one of the very first and big open
source successes in Europe and so the
nature of where the partners had come
from seemed very appealing
where I met Richard Richard near head
who is a serial entrepreneur in the
London office and over time we we try to
make a few investments in space but they
didn't quite fit to invest in Caesar
sort of notions we decided to branch out
and create fabric and fabric is
effectively a venture capital fund so a
long term front a near fund
taking multi-year positions
to decentralized networks interweb
3-space we're quite agnostic to equity
token shaft safes as long as ultimately
we hold the asset that accrues value
over time we're seeing more and more
early-stage equity rounds that might or
might not lead to a token in the long
term but that's sort of quite flexible
point for us where did the name fabric
come from that's a very good question
so Richard is convinced that you were
sitting in the bar in Amsterdam and saw
a shop called fabric right in front of
him and that's where the idea came from
I am personally convinced that I came up
with the idea as well so we we have some
we're a slack message that we haven't
been able to pick up yet because we
haven't paid for slack Pro yet to be
able to verify who actually came up with
the name but your fabric is that first
of all we're building this this mesh or
this fabric which will underpin the web
3 wave and we're backing those people
that are building it and it's
effectively a support structure for the
next wave of the Internet and that's
what fabric is got if someone supposed
to imply yeah that makes some sense then
obviously your background right is like
the quintessential background for seeing
the value that something like this can
bring right I think a lot of people in
the United States for example they don't
they haven't lived a life that they've
seen the negative impacts of the
Internet right that the kind of most
negative impact is probably hey somebody
tried to meddle in our election or you
know look there's hate on the internet
which look it is not a good thing but
the idea of true surveillance the things
that a government can do to oppress
people is kind of a another degree of
bad [ __ ] that frankly maybe talk a
little bit about you know what is some
of that stuff that's actually done I
think people here like oh the
surveillance state like go through a
little bit of like what does that
actually mean in countries outside the
United States yeah absolutely and I well
I come close to knowing what it actually
does I didn't actually live through it I
grew up in Luxembourg so that was quite
a cozy place to live up but to grow up
but I grew up with the stories of my
family who obviously lived through that
so a bit of background
grandparents
invest professors writers who obviously
as intellectual were intellectuals were
considered to be enemies of estates
measure as well and so they lived
through a regime where their neighbors
were reporting on them because the state
had something on them or they depending
on where they would pay them and when
the communist regime and Romania fell in
89 a few years later they released all
of the papers that the government had on
individuals my grandfather got a stack
of about 500 pages of reports from from
neighbors friends I've been reporting
that he'd been eating chicken soup for
lunch or that his daughter was speaking
French on the phone and it doesn't hit
one as hard when you think about it from
didn't an external perspective but when
you know that a state that doesn't
necessarily want the best for you it's
constantly watching you and knows every
step you take on a daily basis that's
scary and there's a really interesting
philosophers who have written about it
but do you take Foucault or Bentham
about you about the idea of an optical
prison where you have a single hope not
because business effectively you have
prison with a single guard in the middle
that is in a glass tower and can observe
every single inmate but none of you and
Mase know whether they being watched or
not and that creates an effect where the
fear of being watched and not knowing
what are you being watched or not it's
actually enough of a power to affect
your human behavior and so that's one of
the big pieces that equip it out and
when you portray that back into what
happened in in a lot of these sort of
civilian States you had this government
which was all-powerful because they
didn't have to watch you but they knew
that you were afraid of the fact that
maybe they are watching you and that
affects everything that affects from how
you're speaking who you're talking to
and then it goes a lot further where'd
they take away passports
and so family didn't have got their
pathways taken away for a pretty long
time until the regime fell I couldn't
travel you depend on the state for food
rations for food stamps across the board
it's it's very difficult to place to
live in and one of the main realization
is that well one might think whatever
money when I think about different
regimes but quite often they start as a
almost attractive
sort of vision that one can sell I think
they get in power somehow I get in power
is somehow and then they lure you in
with something that might look like an
interesting sort of movement to be a
part of and very quickly because of how
human nature behaves and because some of
these people are absolutely despicable
people they turn it into a terrible
state to live in and so that's why I
think some of the webseries ideas are so
interesting because you move from you
shift away from this idea that oh we
won't be evil to oh you just can't be
evil no matter what you try to do and I
think that's one of the aspects that
resonates the most with me where I don't
quite want to equate sort of detector
today with some of the most horrendous
government and it have existed over the
past that sort of century but Chris
Nixon has really good post about this
where most platforms are and it's sort
of attract attract attract mode early on
to get that critical velocity in terms
of users and once they have them they
obviously try to extract stuff and then
that switch happens and all of a sudden
the user is dependent on the state or
depending on the platform you can't
really move away from it or very
difficulty and they have full power of
what they do to you they can sell on
your data they can charge increased
prices they can block off your API
access if you're a developer working on
top of another platform and that
radically changes lives and people
obviously if you're a sort of corporate
shareholder you're happy because they're
high your profits or they're having more
control or they have a more sneaky I
think but amongst users but it's a
radical problem than not instead of a
human problem do you think that so let's
take let list ik go away from the social
networks for a second and let's go to
like a Netflix right so Netflix
announces hey we're gonna increase
prices and there's relatively no impact
on the business right in terms of people
leaving or not even really an uproar
right I would argue that in that
scenario what they're doing is they were
actually under priced right and there
was a lot of price insensitivity and now
Netflix is getting closer to price
equilibrium that price discovery I don't
think that's a very controversial idea
no that's perfectly fine and generally I
think if you're paying for a service it
means you probably like it yeah to pay
for it and yeah we have a Netflix of
fiction and when they increase the price
it made no difference to us because the
value we get out of Netflix we consider
it to be
any larger my bigger problem sits with
the companies and business models if you
will that sit on the idea of hey here's
something for free here is something
that everybody else is doing so you
should be doing it as well and that
grows with sort of network effects and
it grows quite as potentially and then
once they have had that growth and sort
of locked you in then they say oh by the
way your data we're gonna sell that on
oh by the way your observe location
tracking yes i'm company they're
interesting in that and because we don't
charge you we're gonna have to sell that
on as well and very quickly you get to a
point and so if it's small erosions one
after another but quickly you get to a
point where not only do they know you
better than you might know yourself but
they might be able to predict better
what you will do in the future because
you're around you're acting as an
emotional being and they have a rational
sort of data-driven approach to it it's
this whole idea somebody said to me one
time no one would sign up for any social
network where there's Twitter Facebook
you know Instagram whatever if on the
front page it said you know give us your
email and we're gonna sell it to all
these people you know get sign up and
we're gonna track where everywhere you
go right like a if all of the
disclosures were kind of on the homepage
no one would sign up that's pretty
probably the reasons for which
disclosures are 59 pages of small text
really disincentivize anyone from
reading them well and also I would argue
that not only are they presented in a
interesting way rhetoric or a hard to
comprehend way but also a lot of that
stuff to your point comes later on right
nobody I don't know of a single social
networking social product where people
said hey on the day we start we're going
to do X Y or Z right and the other thing
too is you know I always push back on
people who say that Facebook sells data
right
they don't sell your personal data in
the sense that people think right it's
not like hey somebody you know an
academic comes and or a research comes
and says hey give me the data on max
what they do we don't researcher
probably cares enough for that exactly
sits there doing that type of stuff in
terms of aggregate anonymized
that but they're also doing is they're
doing targeting right and the reason why
I think the difference is so important
is selling my data right to your point
is I don't know if it's really that
important to 99% of people who go buy it
right maybe there's somebody trying to
hurt me or something that could buy
it would be powerful but the targeting
to me is there's a psychological
component of it changes the content you
see right it it kind of inhibits or acts
on what you do in the real world right
it convinces you to go places or buy
things or interact with people like that
the repercussions of that I think is not
well studied and frankly not well
understood yeah and especially if you if
you take it to a political level where I
mean as trying to be intellectually
honest with ourselves generally we try
to get out of our echo chambers which
you know I suffered quite a bit with
Twitter where it seems that everybody
has similar interest to me but getting
the other side of the table is always
important and if you live on social
media and you get all of your
information from social media you
obviously get targeted into these echo
chambers specifically the ones that
either sort of corporates or social
media platforms or buyers of there are
targeting systems one key to be and and
that creates well I think it creates a
lot of problems that we've had with
critical ecosystem recently which is not
necessarily that the wrong side one you
might have whatever opinion you might
have on that whether it's brexit whether
it's mac Hong whether it's Trump and
Clinton but the whole problem is that
the the large majority of the campaigns
were driven by fear so they were driven
by what you don't want I'm pretty
certain that in the u.s. the large
majority of Trump voters were voting
against Clinton and the large majority
of Clinton George was reporting against
Trump in the UK we've had the same thing
with brexit where I think a lot of
people who voted in favor of brexit were
basically voting against the European
Union and evil people in Brussels in
Luxembourg who were dictating what they
could and couldn't do equally with with
Michael in France Michael came a bit
have no out of nowhere and got a lot a
bit of popularity but he ultimately won
because people rallied against Murray
independence or the far-right candidate
and when you have that targeting that is
so specific and you have someone who is
literally native and can actually use
that to their advantage
it changes politics which is probably
the biggest agent in the world in the
part that has really shocked me I think
is how effective some candidates are
compared to everyone else so in the u.s.
if you take you know one person on each
side of the aisle you've got a president
Trump and then you've got a AOC right
and both of them have
a skill at using these platforms and
tools that most of their peers don't
have and you know look again it's people
on both sides of the aisle they can do
all this and what what surprised me is
how well-received it is by the audience
right to somebody like you and I who you
know it's our job to understand
technology how people use it it's very
obvious right look you're using things
to go viral and you're spreading a
message it's you know propaganda from
one category it's marketing from the
other category right but I'm shocked at
how few of their contemporaries have
picked up on what's happening and
figured out how to do it themselves and
brings this question of like our digital
natives right even though you know take
Trump is a little bit older obviously
but people who understand how to use
these tools are they at such an
advantage that nobody else can catch up
right if you look at some of the
hearings that they had with Mark
Zuckerberg it was impressive to hear to
the extent to which some of the members
did not necessarily understand how
Facebook technology works it's about the
highest level and so indeed there isn't
a huge advantage to being able to use
the digital route whether it's in
politics and economics whether it's in
business you see a lot of companies that
are sprung out of basically their
marketing campaigns I mean you've
mentioned on podcast recently I believe
that you're a marketing or naturalizing
business that is monetizing a via an
investment fund yeah and that resonated
a lot because ultimately what you're
doing is you're gaining attention and
you are indeed making the mesons of
investments because of that attention
you tweeted yesterday or two days ago so
I'm looking to make a seed investment
what do you recommend I should look at
and all of a sudden you had over 500
recommendations it's tilaka yeah people
talk about proprietary deal flow when
you're fundraising
what better proprietor will you have not
it is so it's now up over for those that
didn't see it might weed and said I'm
looking like a pre seed investment
basically you know what company should I
look at or what I wish I invest in and
it's now over 1,500 different companies
recommended now I check that that's 500
yeah well so here's the crazy part is I
think there will be five or less that
are things that we are excited about and
want to invest in right so it's a very
small number but
to your point we found out of those 1500
there's probably a thousand we didn't
know about right and and it's just there
we're talking about a global world where
there's people in every corner building
companies and nobody knows about them
right it's it's literally people are
DMing me and saying hey you know I work
in a we work in whatever city in the
world and I haven't told anyone what I'm
building yet I'd love for you to take a
look pretty cool the flip side of that
is how do you synthesize all that
information right and the curation game
they're after
exactly you've got the funnel open
you've got the attention he said
transcribed out to a political game
you've got the eyeballs of the
population looking at you then it's up
to you to convince them it's up to you
and your investor all to curate and find
the right ones yep but if you don't have
that's a funnel open in the first place
element to like for an investor you like
to take that stereo right so I've got to
look through 1500 companies and try to
find the ones that I like when you're a
voter there's only two or three
candidates right so so there's much more
kind of tribalism in the sense that you
only got three positions and most people
have been convinced that it is
unpatriotic to not vote right in the
sense that if you don't like any of the
three candidates absolving from voting
is not appropriate and what that does is
then it forces you to vote against
somebody right who do I'd not like the
most out of these two or three
okay I'm gonna vote for the other side
right so in Luxembourg given it's a
small country actually the vote is an
obligation a legal obligation it's not a
bad interesting patriotic but to the
point of you end up voting against
someone instead of for someone and that
pushes the messaging into a certain
direction and it pushes the messaging
into the direction of defamation of
attacks of insults which moves away from
the sort of an honest political
discourse that we used to have in the
past and the thing that worries me there
is if you look at sort of Ahana aren't
mentioned and one of her books which I
find it was a fascinating idea is that
the main premise for a totalitarian
regime whether it be on the left or on
the right it's the moment when people
mix up
reality and fantasy and unfortunately
once they're getting into a defamation
game especially with these mass channels
of social media or of news which 10 20
years ago were able to reach in order of
magnitude for those people at half the
speed you move towards actually sort of
blurring those lines between reality and
fantasy and that's its massive problem
we'll starting now with the fake stories
but very quickly we'll get into deep
fake videos where you will not be able
to tell the difference between a
favorite video of Obama saying something
versus the real one absolutely yeah look
the the deep fake stuff is is
fascinating because it's not just audio
it's not just video it's a whole bunch
of this stuff and the part that you know
I keep going back to is if you have any
amount of content on the internet right
I mean whether it's writing your voice
video at some point that is going to be
able to be manipulated and the part that
I think scares me is less like go to a
court of law
right because in a court of law there's
gonna be experts and there's gonna be
technology that validates or doesn't
validate it's more of the like social
discourse right and that's been 30
seconds glances over it see that yeah it
looks good enough checks out
I believe yeah and it's your friend
who's mad that you said something right
there's no court of law there's no
technology validation right it's just oh
that guy's an [ __ ] now because I
can't believe he said that to fake a
video right it can be on the friendship
it can be on with small business can be
a large business that really
relationships like you know romantic
relationships all this stuff like that
there will be serious ripple effects
from the ability to create fake content
and again it's we know it's gonna be a
problem we probably can't stop it right
and the part to me that is really
interesting is while we are accelerating
technology we spend 90 plus percent of
our intellectual horsepower accelerating
that technology and we spend very very
little of it trying to understand the
impacts on society right and we kind of
just deal with that later
that's being able to move fast break
things syrian of Silicon Valley but to
the point of of what we can do actually
against college GPA videos I think part
of it is that historically you can
really replicate my speech because it
was nice I'm online indeed you can
replicate it you can create a copy you
can slightly modify it you can create
hundred copies you can flood someone
with them and so there the idea of
digital scarcity comes in what if I put
up a video and I sign it with my private
keys and all of a sudden that video is
unique and unless a video of me is
signed with my prodigy that's not it
doesn't come from me
so one sort of the UX problem goes away
from that I see a future where with
digital seriously you're able to
actually have much better control around
these fake videos they audio fake tax
etc absolutely how how does your guys
investment thesis play into all this so
let's talk about like what you guys are
excited about investing in thematically
and then we could talk about some of the
nuances yesterday so the way we see the
the web through ecosystem is roll call
it work through the whole bit there's
three courses that are sort of playing
out there's a sound money thesis and
which I'm a big fan of I think bitcoin
got it I smoke pretty much all into the
space in the first place
but it's not really the space of venture
fund anymore because bitcoin is a large
market cap it's also a liquid market cap
you don't really get a relationship with
the team because if we never see Satoshi
has been also and there's a whole buncha
different contributors to it and so the
other two that we probably spend most of
our time on is on one side you've got
sort of the web three C's thesis and on
one side you've got the digital assets a
passive thesis on the digital asset
front I have no doubt that we'll agree
on this but I don't see a future where
there is not a digital version of every
single physical good out there because
if you can have a version which is free
software so it's infinitely programmable
it's divisible it's has a much higher
liquidity pool it's easily transferable
across the globe it just makes sense
that every single good will be digitized
at some point and then what you open up
with that is sort of it's all open
finance stack where not only can you
create and custody assets for much
cheaper but also you can transfer them
across the globe and you can build
applications on top of that so if you
think about what maker data is done
today if you can
openness EDP puts on Ethan and get alone
programmatically without having to
interface with any human at any point in
time but in the future when I go to a
multilateral dive what if you can
invoice your you can recognize your
invoice or you can tokenize your house
all of a sudden you can lock that up in
your CDP and then you can unlock working
capital with your unpaid invoice and
that unlocks a huge amount of different
workflows and more capital that just
locked up in today's economy that sort
of one of them and the second one is
sort of the web story thesis which is
that if you think back to how the web
group web one was largely focused on
e-commerce it was desktop first and it
was very heavily dependent on expensive
infrastructure that was custom built and
dedicated for each individual business
and so that slowly shifted to web 2 when
you had a few things that weren't you
did you had a social layer and which
meant that people could trust each other
recommendations became possible and so
you were able to interact with people
across the globe via trusted
intermediaries but you were not sort of
limited to the people around you that
you trusted secondly there was the
mobile with the introduction of the
iPhone mainly but the mobile revolution
which meant that instead of sitting on
your desktop a couple of hours a day all
of a sudden you had your phone in your
pocket
pretty much every every hour of the day
and so you were interacting with web to
much higher frequency and certainly
there was a cloud aspect which meant
that actually spinning up a business
from a developer perspective were found
with respect it became a lot cheaper
because you didn't need to have that
sort of dedicated infrastructure you
could iterate very quickly experiment
and that's how a lot of these businesses
that have came to fruition and it's a
combination of those three pillars or
layers that lived to have likes of uber
is an app ever being beat of the day
today which if you think back 10 years
ago or 15 years ago it would have been
incredible or unbelievable that you
convinced someone to get into a
stranger's car simply because you pulled
out an application on your phone and
called for them and we believe that sort
of the next wave of web story will
largely be built on three similar layers
one of them is this proliferation of
edge computing is the computing stack
has been pushed out to the very limits
of yet
this in your eye o t devices on a farm
in Kansas it's on your health tracking
device it's an D D on your phone your
car your house and so the amount of data
points that are generated by the IOT
devices I sprung up massively it's nor
the amount of magnitude higher and on
the sort of obvious I know that you've
got machine learning algorithms and sort
of a Renaissance of AI which means that
actually some of these machine learning
algorithms are able to do efficient
things with the data for any and between
that you've got this fabric or mesh
which is a decent raised data structure
which means that you don't have detect I
inserted a that silo all their data and
effectively or you only must benefit
from it but instead you can you're able
to bring in the long tail of data
generators which are able to monetize
and sell their data onto some of these
machine learning algorithms or data
scientists or and this can be humans
machines animals in the future and that
physical unlocks huge amount of value in
terms of what what becomes possible to
interact what crew can interact in this
economy but also it really fundamentally
shifts the power structure from what I
mentioned earlier it moves you from
these tech giants that are promising
that they won't be able to all of a
sudden you've got this peer-to-peer
architecture which is fundamentally
can't be evil and so that's one of the
main thesis around which we've built a
fund we think that early on must be
focused on developers right now it's a
developer tool stack is probably one of
the ones that's getting the most
attraction every time we'll move instead
of open finances to starting to take
office well
the healthcare space is prone to have a
huge amount of personal data that you
don't want to have sort of siloed in
with tech giants but rather you want to
be able to monetize that yourself or not
even monetize a little bit keep it
private and only selectively share
certain data points when you go see a
certain doctor but not leave that data
with them the supply chain space the
automotive space and especially do
autonomous automotive space they're all
prone to to really benefit from these
new sort of shared data structures how
much of what you're excited about in the
web 3 world is web 2 things that are
kind of updated or modernized versus
these are brand new solutions in tech
that did not exist in web 2 but they're
solving some of the same problems that
are attacking from a different Avenue
that that just looks different
if for that I mean it's really
interesting question and ultimately I
think we'll always end up taking the
steps of well just like the very first
applications of digital was to digitize
the New York Times and that was an
interesting thing to do but it doesn't
didn't fundamentally change the world
and so I think it's important to take a
step back and look at sort of the
history of business models that have
evolved via the web to and try to draw
some analogies to web 3 as well and see
where they where they might take us if
you like a web to some of the very early
business models that arose were indeed
some digitizing content which seems
simple might it make it slightly more
distributable got a higher reader base
and so it was interesting but ultimately
the businesses that really took off were
business models that were not really
imaginable before if you consider open
source open source is contributing about
400 billion dollars worth of value today
only on a yearly basis do if you follow
certain reports if you consider a sort
of de sharing economy it would never
have been possible to even imagine that
you might share your apartment with a
random stranger because you let them in
via an application even the SAS economy
it was never imaginable that you could
spring up a heuristic cloud-based
infrastructure and on-demand and grow
your business or grow your
infrastructure with your business and so
a lot of these evolved from positions
that seemed to be impossible I did
survive steps and now they become
evident and if you look sort of traced
back now as to where the the early web 3
what business models live the very first
one I guess was issuing your own asset
in a sort of currency asset type so
Bitcoin being the first one at some
point it's very involved money Manero zk
etc and then some his business models
that were built on top of that you had
the sort of block streams of the world
and consensus of the world who said ok
we're gonna hold a bunch of the native
asset
box 3 moles bunch of Bitcoin consensus a
bunch of ether and we're just gonna make
the network more valuable so our
business model is not revenue generating
but rather it's just depreciation of
value of that native asset that we hold
and then you had a business model on top
of that which said hey this asset is
super volatile
why don't we tax volatility and that
sort of exchanges the custodians and
that enabled that and took these sort of
in traditional business models and then
we started exploring what's possible
outside of currency the very first sort
of utility token models which I'm not a
big fan of the word utility token but
it's just been aggregated into that
where payment tokens where people said
hey we're gonna create a two thousand
marketplace
and that's gonna be on a peer-to-peer
basis people will be able to interact
with us but they need to use our
currency that have to be able to trade
between themselves there's a lot of ther
criticisms of that people to try to
apply some vehicle speak use an equation
of exchange it's a value that
fundamentally I don't think that really
applies first Phyllis is 110 year old
equation
ident economic identity I believe you've
got people like Milton Friedman saying
that actually the V part of em vehicles
PQ is just a fudge factor to make the
equation work and so when people
criticize the velocity problem it's not
really done applicable you know and
ultimately I think a lot of products I
realized that there is no rational
reason for value to approve two such
payment tokens right now where these
hasn't played out yet and so people are
moving away from that one of the most
interesting areas of for business models
that I think fundamentally changes the
game our work tokens or we can consider
them to be sort of supply-side focused
explain what those are so taking an
analogy may be the easiest way is to
consider it in like a taxi medallion
given we are in the urine after all
right now you hold a taxi medallion you
get the right to drive a taxi and you
get revenues those revenues are paid to
you in dollars or whatever currency
stable coin you might want but you're
not being paid in that native asset and
so that native asset is purely focused
on coordinating the supply side of a
network and so you've got networks like
youth network
I like auger and like zip and we're
focused on providing certain services
where people can then come on to the
network use them pay in in dollars and
the reason for which they accrue value
is that as more and more people start
using the network and there's more and
more revenues flowing to all of these
holders of live assets and so given
there's a limited supply of these assets
people will buy them and their value
should go up theoretically or in a
rational manner and now we've got this
whole so it's taking economy that's
building up around that where people are
buying these assets taking them to get
so part of the block rewards but also
part of the fees and the reason we're so
excited about them is not only do they
have a very rational value accrual
mechanism where you can see okay it's
not a central company that's getting all
these revenues but they're collect a
collective of all these asset holders
which are providing work to the network
are getting a certain amount of fees
paid out to them
and you can probably build your your
valuation model bit based on the DCF on
that model but also it's actually it's
fantastic coordination tool it's and it
will only really work if it provides
better or cheaper service than the
centralized entities do but if you
consider its own file count for example
and they're unlocking all of this free
space that is sitting idle on your
computer on my computer on my phone that
was just never used before and so given
that it's not being used for anything
else I can massively undercut any
centralized entity that is paying for
every single gigabytes that they provide
and so the coordination mechanism
coupled with the fact that you have a
clear revenue stream for all of these
tokens always makes a lot of sense from
a business model perspective and going
forward will once your huge amount of
other experimentation if you think about
governance circuits if people think in
terms of business models if you think
about providing UX and UI to some of
these networks I mean so all grid went
live a few months ago as one of the sort
of first networks actually go live
very quickly a business building on top
of that avail you have flats in Europe
you have Gesser in Europe and we're
building the interface to be able to
interact with this network and they will
try to extract some small fee but they
are providing a lot of value to the user
and in the thought process here is to
take like a veil etc is the network the
infrastructure that's built there the
mechanism is applicable in many
different use cases to different
audiences and what these people are
building on top of those networks is
very targeted interfaces for a specific
use case to a specific audience right
it's almost like the network itself the
product market fit is is found through
an interface right and those interface
is being built on top then have to find
the product market fit between like the
network and the user rights almost like
a user network fit I guess is found by
building a specific interface yeah
absolutely
if you take the case of augur you might
have users who just want to bet on
sports gaming because they can't forget
other means you might have other users
you want to hedge against currency risk
it's obviously a very different users
and have different performance that will
top of that and on top of the network
for those different users but also the
other thing it does is for the user it
really removes the platform risk because
if I have a large hedge on currency on
your network and I've placed that with
the avail but all of a sudden the fatal
shuts down
well I can probably retrieve that the I
guess or I can go through a tour and
interact with that and so it removes the
risk that's the company that you're
interacting with is able to shut you
down
business mm-hmm it's super interesting
what areas of crypto do you think people
are not talking about but should be
paying more attention to I was talking
about should be paying more attention I
think a really interesting topic that is
starting to creep into conversation and
it's actually a pretty controversial one
when you see the conversations going on
about it but is the idea of
sustainability of open-source software
development and given I can't say all I
would like to say all but unfortunately
not of crypto is open source it's a big
problem so a lot of people come from it
with the Bitcoin angle where one of the
core characteristics is it's
immutability there are 21 there will be
21 in Bitcoin and that will never change
and there are questions of what happens
once the block rewards serve dies out
world transaction fees behind enough to
incentivize miners to come provide hash
power to secure the network that will
happen sort of far enough down the line
but the more urgent or imminent
conversation is around aetherium there's
a lot of discussion around ERC 1 7 8 9
by Kevin Waukee from get coin actually
put that out recently of how do you
incentivize the core developers because
right now 100 percent block reward goes
to miners why is there not 20 percent of
that that goes to the core developers
were actually trading the network it
just makes sense
people are maintaining at the network
they get paid people like rating or
developing or improving the network they
should also get paid and there's a few
projects that are trying to solve that
get coin is one there was marked out by
I mean there's a company called OS coin
and that we actually invested in it's
fantastic team left-terrorists and
alexei who are thinking about it on a
broader scale but you're building a
decentralized github so you removed
depending from github but you also have
a incentivization on top of it where
based off of the dependencies of
different yet op reports the
repositories are open source software
projects they get paid out a part of the
block reward and there's some incredible
stats around that where 65% of all open
source projects are maintained by one or
two people 94% of action developers are
using open source software so you've got
this whole economy our entire economy is
built on open source software from the
Facebook's we Google Amazon to the world
they're all using open source software
and yet a lot of these projects 93% of
NPM packages have one maintainer and
this is one maintainer is not being paid
who's doing it as a hobby and they make
my very well quit to the next day
because they're getting harassed by all
nine communities and so find a
sustainable model to support these these
maintainers I think it's one of the most
important problems that not enough
people are talking about absolutely what
um what do you think is over-height area
of crypto like something that everyone
is talking about this they should shut
up about well I think prices on a day to
day basis and obviously we have a
different perspective given we're taking
a venture capital approach and so we're
all investments we make our with a
multi-year outlook but on a day to day
basis I think prices are unfortunately
the most talked-about aspect she's used
to measure right she just measure it the
best one I don't know
I mean prices have been down a huge
amount this year if you consider what
I've actually going on an ecosystem what
development is going on it's all sort of
to the top right if you look at sort of
a theory mattress is there 60 million US
air mattress it's already million added
in the past year so they've doubled if
you look at sort of unspent transaction
I put on Bitcoin there at all-time high
now again after the sort of peaking in
January 2018 if you look at solidity
developers on a serum you've got sort of
zeppelin west they've reached over
500,000 downloads of open
truffula ganache of over a million
downloads if you like it maker which is
actually probably one of the few
projects that have hit product market
fit in some shape or form they've issued
more loans and then Lending Club did in
five years in their first year and
interestingly if you look at the dates
yeah I've got that chart which goes from
to the zero to two hundred million and
that charge starts on the January 2018
which is a very peak of the bubble so
the price has gone down word from there
and all of a sudden you've got sort of
this product which just takes off from
that point in time and so I think a lot
of the developments are super positive
even if you look at several corporates
Samsung is not going to be issuing their
key management service to all of their
as ten phones that's 10 to 50 million
people that will have key management
built into their phones you've got JP
Morgan which is launching their own
quite whatever you might think about
what the JP Morgan coin might be worth
if we don't even know how it's gonna be
what exactly you will do in the end but
that's a stamp of approval from the bank
we're sort of the CEO a few years ago
was saying that bitcoin was doomed to
fail and we would never touch it
all of a sudden you've got them issuing
their own central currency and so from
that perspective huge amount of positive
developments and yet people are talking
about price which has indeed been down
now yes the past few months have been
the first to positive months in a row
since June last year but still I wish we
talked more about the technical
development and less about price
absolutely before I wrap up I was asked
a rapid-fire set of questions what do
you think is the most important company
in crypto company other than fabric of
course probably consensus and parity
okay why those two I think
so again just so coming back to the idea
of pricing I'm sure all the people
probably think coin base and Finance are
the most important companies in crypto
they're great because they bring access
to the volatility and people can trade
on it but they're not fundamentally
doing as much work as consensus and
parity in developing the underlying
technology it is somewhat through my
view somewhat focused on this area and I
admit that but parity has done a huge
amount and we are investors in focus so
that's full disclosure there but parity
is on a huge amount of work
for this erroneous system they built one
of the first clients Dave but a lot of
solutions early on and they've been
doing that relentlessly for the past
couple of years
consensus have built a majority of tools
that we use it on a day to day basis on
three of their network if you consider
and through our truffling and ganache
which most of the serum ecosystem is
built upon there's been built by
consensus and Joe Lubin has a tremendous
amount of work and capital into the
space and I don't think that gets
recognized enough mm-hmm what what do
you feel is the one regulation you would
change or improve with you could I think
there could be a lot more clarity on
regulation it's an interesting sort of
comparison between the US and Europe in
the u.s. you've got to be SEC and CFTC
that is pushing things forward with
slowly yep in Europe you've got a bunch
of nation states that I wanted to come
to hotspot for crypto
just like switchman and luxembourg with
hotspot for banking a lot of smaller
countries are realizing that there's a
big opportunity to be the most crypto
friendly ecosystem for foundries to come
to Entre Nous so you got multi you've
got your belt or you've got Switzerland
I which have all issued very clear
statements in terms of regulation of
what is a security what isn't a security
how you can issue it or how you can
launch the network and equally you've
got some of the bigger countries France
the Minister of Economy Bruno LeMay has
mentioned that he wants France to be
sort of thought about in Europe for
crypto Britain has made some pretty
clear advancements to creating a script
a task force to provide clarity on what
assets are securities what assets are
not securities heart attacks etc so all
of these things seem like they're moving
in the right direction because of that
competitive nature
where's in the US it feels like it's
slightly slower because they know they
have no competition if you're based in
the US you're gonna be launching to us
anyways and so they can take their time
and I think that's slightly hampering
the u.s. because families are not
certain what what they can launch where
they can launch and they might move away
from the US every time and we'll see how
that plays out but I think it's a lot of
clarity would be much better it makes
sense yeah what um what's most important
book you've ever read I probably go with
Milan Kundera French what was that in
translation it's the Unbearable
Lightness of being
okay explained it's as I'm not a big fan
of the business
it's not in that it's a Czech writer who
moved away because I become a three-team
they're moved to France start writing in
French but there's two core ideas which
I think really matter or still stand out
to me in that book one of them is that
he sort of negates on Nietzsche's idea
of the eternal return I think we
constantly live our lives comparing to
what could have been if I had done that
what would have happened if you look
should I could have would have type
mentality and he sort of pushes back on
that is that there is no eternal return
there is no hundred thousand or millions
of sort of parallel realities where you
can compare to the moment something
happens you should forget about it it
sort of loses its importance because
it's done and you should move on to the
next thing in a second I really like
about that work and service shaped my
view quite a bit is on a political
nature is that sort of three different
characters that are living through life
in Czechoslovakia during a communist
regime and all of them come to the same
realization that the political party is
very rarely or almost never in favor of
the individual they always try to
subvert you via the same means whether
they be on the left around the right and
ultimately they press you to take
actions based off of what you don't like
when what he dislike and what we
discussed earlier on and I think
unfortunately a lot of that is playing
out today and I think a lot of
literature is is has been a really good
predictor of that so other books adopted
as of 1984 by by Orwell actually a
recent one that we we gifted out to a
few of our close friends was on tyranny
by miles by Schneider which is some
twenty lessons from the 20th century
mainly focus on the Communists and not
see I'm reading it right now it's
actually fascinating it's incredible how
much how many parallels there are today
yeah absolutely speaking of parallels
parallel universes um aliens real or not
I hope Richard Burton really introduced
me to a whole bunch of other aliens he
claims they are real and they live on
earth in terms of parallel universes
I think the probabilistic chance that
there are no aliens it's infinitely
small
the question of whether we want to meet
them yet I think probably not why not
well partly due to the fact that I
watched life which I killed how recently
and they have this small character
called Calvin which is turns into this
horrible monster and so that change in
my mind but because we we can barely
deal with ourselves on planet earth as a
single human society I don't want about
how we will deal with people who have
different or people or aliens who have
different views and different mannerisms
and maybe overwhelming more power than
us that makes sense and it's also we
don't know what we don't know right I
think we have to figure out our stuff
out on ourselves here first before we
start exploring the rest I think yeah
space travel is extremely exciting and
will come out of it will maybe leads to
technical innovations that we couldn't
even imagine but I think we should be
careful would you rather go to space or
go to the depths of the ocean generally
both of them include sort of small
capsules in long travel time I'm not a
big fan of small spaces and so your
morale is just like I got a good life
let me just hang out here on the crust
of the earth but if if I had to take one
the ocean after the ocean over space is
probably sort of float back up at some
points whereas in space it's a good
point like whether you're alive or not
probably doesn't matter as much as like
at least on the on the ocean they've got
a set area to look for you exactly all
right that makes sense what one question
you have for me to close it out so I
think you've probably spend a lot of
time just like us trying to convince
people who don't necessarily believe in
the space yet or I don't see that it's
it's value accrual or don't see its
merits what is the one narrative that
you've seen work best across the board
for people who haven't been done yeah
it's all separate this into public and
private markets public being all the
liquid crypto
the narrative there is just we're
talking about non
related or low correlation assets that
have an asymmetric return profile so
whether you believe in these assets
being valid or not whenever you have
those criteria or aspects to an asset if
you believe in Modern Portfolio theory
and you put those assets into that
portfolio there's benefits that come
with it right and so kind of making the
what I call the investors investment
argument of like if you are a pure
investor and you look at unemotional
decisions around assets emotion can be
both bullish and bearish right and so
just the non correlation and the
asymmetric return profile I think really
resonates with investors and then in the
private markets I look somebody told me
very ah when I started investing follow
the talent just if you follow the talent
they'll lead you you know to the holy
world it's the Holy Grail and and every
time I've ever done that we have been
very happy with the result and when I've
strayed from that we have not been happy
with the result right so so there's this
element of like it is more true than
even you would you admit to yourself
once you know that and the argument I
make is look the smartest people in the
water rushing in to build this and
capital is following them and anytime
you have that you know just density of
intellectual capital going somewhere and
also the financial capital following
that that momentum is very hard to
overcome or break away from and so we
think that there's a lot of innovation a
lot of value that's going to be built
here and it just is that intellectual
financial capital that kind of is the
that the tailwind if you will that that
really pushes us forward
if that little experimentation will not
lead to nothing yeah and it also you
notice I didn't have to say anything
about crypto or block chain or Bitcoin
or any of that stuff and you know look
we get into the weeds with you know
plenty of investors but I do think those
two narratives or stories around look
this is true of every asset right it
doesn't matter you could take Bitcoin
out and put rocks right and if it's not
correlated in a symmetric we would be
saying the same thing right if you look
at private markets and anytime you can
see a single vertical in the private
markets where tons of innovation is
happening because talent is coming in
and capital is coming in we would say
the same thing right and so it removes
the
attachment and the part that I've been
impressed with is the investors who can
keep a sober mindset and be realistic
and somewhat grounded end up be going
from I don't even understand this stuff
is it real - oh well with do that
framework I really believe and they've
lenient very hard very quickly and so
it's been pretty cool to see that kind
of flip that switch for a couple of
investors and hopefully they'll be play
more listen we are all we are all doing
this together but it is it is fun and
look you are you're on another side of
the world that frankly there's probably
not as many people being as loud about
this as in the United States and in
North America so so I'm incredibly
impressed with what you guys are doing
and I'll have to do this again to catch
up after after you guys make some more
progress I'm looking forward to it thank
you